let's look at
charlie the emilio this is charlie and
her happy little family look at that
here she comes out of nowhere and
becomes an amazing
influencer and no less than hulu is
giving him a show that means at the end
of last year when the kardashians went
off the year
charlie the emilio becomes like the
number one or number two
total celebrity on the united states on
tick tock
and so charlie the emilia with i think
it was 20 million followers or something
amazing like that
hulu comes and gives her a show so
charlie and her family are going to be
on a show so now
the kardashians are off the air and all
that they stood for they're older
they're married they have all these kids
it's been a good run for them
and now tick tock has birthed a brand
new show
remember tick tock wasn't even really
prevalent united states pre-2018
and here we are two years and a couple
months later
we have now created what is a potential
big money replacement for the
kardashians
that's huge then let's look at this girl
olivia rodrigo she's from disney high
school musical
cute girl really nice a lot of people
following her
she did this new song so songs are also
suddenly being conquering points on
tick tock she drops this new song i
think it's called driver's license and
she drops it on january 8th
76 million streams in the course of a
week
and suddenly she's number one on
billboard hot 100.
that's amazing then on january 11th she
shatters spotify's individual record
with what
15 million streams in the course of one
week
so take a look you're going from here to
here and suddenly you're giving birth to
new celebrities
that are getting tv shows and are
actually crushing
quantitative data 15 million streams
counted that breaks the spotify record
for a new song
there is only one word for what they
have done to influence her marketing and
that is damn
this stuff is here to stay you know it's
just amazing i look back at it i see
sports i see the political intrigue i
saw black lives matters
tick tock was figuring in all of that as
people were making themselves heard
and this important demographic was out
there i mean the sports is what's
i think also very interesting because
you've got so many other sports sites
out there
yet all this influencer marketing was
coming to actually propel certain sports
up
we were watching here in the us as the
nfl and everything coming into the
playoffs
suddenly users were on tick tock and
they're weighing in about their favorite
teams talking about who's going to be in
the super bowl
and then even some of them are talking
about raider nation and i've been a
raider fan forever and it's
just been a long year and watching
everybody else's teams on tick tock you
know
getting all that stuff while the raiders
were kind of
i'm sorry
hi i'm brooker bitchdoc is my dad
sorry he gets like that when he talks
about raider nation
speaking of tick tock this year all the
raiders highlights could fit into one
tick tock video
are you better then come finish your
case study
thank you brooker all right i'm better
now you know if you're a raider nation
fan sometimes life is hard
anyway so you got sports and you got
influences you got all these things
coming
now let's take a look what it means for
you and me as entrepreneurs and what we
do with their businesses
because we're probably not going to
birth the next twitter or the next tick
tock
but we've got a lot of consumers
that are in these categories where
managing digital media is going to
matter
and i think what we need to understand
is that the name of the game
is sell stuff and there's a lot of money
that you could waste on digital media
get with digital media agencies to help
you go
through and to make smart quantitative
purchases
i would recommend whether you're
spending a thousand dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars
you get with a digital media buyer that
can help you navigate through this i
think that's the lesson for the
entrepreneur here
is look media mix is generational it's
not what's hot
it's what's hot with who and when and
why
and then put it together to sell
whatever you're doing
people say oh you need a store on
facebook if you're gonna sell t-shirts
in berlin
the example i've used for three years on
case studies with the biz doc
well the question is is that where
t-shirts in berlin
are bought and is that how you influence
it so remember it's
generational have a media buyer work
through that with you
thanks for watching the short clip if
you like that and like to see the whole
episode
you can find it right here and for even
more
subscribe to this channel right here